[Music]
when we get this up and running we gonna
be out of here Stanford Morehouse
Spellman is it something Einstein spent
his entire life trying to do we proves
that time travel to the past is possible
if we just give it some time scary what
you inspire me
you going places CJ says pops is born I
got to make sure that you get dude I
don't need you always playing Big
Brother I'm the only big brother you got
[Applause]
NYPD move
[Music]
Calvin Walker a 19 year old black teen
was allegedly shot and killed by an NYPD
officer Walker was armed with nothing
but a cell phone I'm so sorry about all
of this I could go back and fix it I
wanted if we just go back get them out
of there
then he saved I really have so many
times to get this right everything's
gonna need to be perfect today's date
June 28th Sebastian this has to work
literally it's about control e something
we obviously have no control over my
brother didn't deserve this just missing
y'all how many times if you jump back CJ
we're not superheroes
where is the justice we can't do
anything here we only have two jumps
left
win-win for the whole nation
you gotta listen to us you're going to
get killed
[Music]